wow you did these freehand yep my god
these could be tracings oh look at this
one wow you nailed it
how much what do you mean I don't see a
price um you want to buy it well yeah
yeah we have to have it for the office I
mean there's my window and there's my
car is that your car huh that is our
building
and we sell paper
I'm really proud of you
thank you
what
do you have something in your pocket
okay I assume and hope you prepared your
own vows Ben you want to say some stuff
about Leslie in my time working for the
stake ever met my job sent me to 46
cities in 11 years I lived in villages
with eight people rural farming
communities college towns I was sent to
every corner of Indiana and then I came
here and I realized that this whole time
I was just wandering around everywhere
just looking for you Leslie do you want
to say some stuff about Ben no okay well
the first draft of my vows which I wrote
the day after we got engaged clocked in
at around 70 pages oh but I don't have
them with me
maybe there's a copy of them that's fine
I think we can just keep going okay
here's what I'll say that the things
that you have done for me to help me
support me surprise me to make me happy
go above and beyond what any person
deserves you're all I need I love you
and I like you I love you I like you
you may ask me out to dinner nothing
fancier fun no bars no patios no
vegetables and no seafood white
[Music]
did I ever tell you why I love Scranton
mm-hmm yeah I didn't think I had well it
was all about Pam yeah I mean she was
with Roy and I just couldn't take it I
mean I lost a toy I couldn't sleep I
couldn't concentrate on anything and
weird stuff like food had no taste so my
solution was to move away it was awful
and it is something that I wouldn't wish
on my worst enemy and that includes you
sergeant Jeffords that's right it's me
sergeant Jeffords from the precinct I'm
the guy whose damn complaint you don't
want to submit and I can't think of one
damn reason why everyone this is
sergeant Jeffords hi I'm sorry for
interrupting your dinner party no
problem at all this is important also
Kevin's friend Margo's here and she's a
real class a trip sir I can't get why
you don't want me to file a complaint I
thought you of all people would support
me first of all let me say what that
office I did to you was wrong deeply
wrong and I'm furious about okay so why
don't you back me up because that
complaint could backfire cops who blow
the whistle on other cops almost always
face the backlash just like people who
socialize with Margo invariably hear
about our trip to Scottsdale you've
really worked up about Margo sorry she's
horrible listen I don't want to see your
career derailed because you will be
smudged for reporting on another officer
but what he did was wrong he should be
besmirched yes but is that besmirching
worth a greater purchasing of your
career you have to balance besmirching
there's politics to being a cop but I
wasn't harassed to being a cop I was
harassed as a black man I'm not saying
do nothing I'm saying the most powerful
action you can take is the rise through
the ranks so that you can make
large-scale changes I've had to pick my
battles and it hasn't always been easy
but now I have my own precinct a
precinct whose officers would never do
to you what officer mount AG did I
understand what you're saying but I hear
Margo's quick issues in the hallway my
guess as to where in Arizona she bought
the last oh great there you are I'm
about to start my Scottsdale slide show
it has all the highlights there are no
highlights in Scottsdale Margo that's
what you think Raymond
Terry I know you're upset but this is
the right thing to do you have this
close to the City Council position and
that's just the beginning it would be a
shame to jeopardize that look I get that
the guys at our precinct wouldn't roll
follow me but it still happened only one
precinct over which is why you need to
keep pushing forward in your career so
that you can change the system Terry
you're a great cop you can become a
chief or higher how long will it take to
make change that way modak is on the
street now you know I became a cop
please share because when I was a kid I
always wanted to be a superhero stop it
stop bothering little teary or what or I
will defeat you
well I wanted to help people like that
cop helped me but right now I don't feel
like a superior I feel the opposite when
I got stopped the other day I wasn't a
cop I wasn't a guy who lived in a
neighborhood looking for his daughters
tour I was a black man a dangerous black
man I saw he could see a threat and I
couldn't stop thinking about my
daughters and their future and how years
from now they could be walking down the
street looking for their kids muumuu and
get stopped by bad cop and they probably
won't get to play the police card to get
out of trouble I don't like that thought
I'm gonna do something about it so I
don't care if it might hurt my career
I'm filing that report even if I have to
go over your head to do it kind of seem
like you're gonna get up and leave after
saying all that alas I think I hear mark
I don't understand that after 15 years
of service here I have to get in the car
and drive to New York in order to talk
to you that doesn't seem right to me
that doesn't seem fair and I think that
I've earned more than that yeah
you're right yes I get it I get it
Michael okay here's what I'm gonna do
okay we will move some money around and
I will personally see to it that you
have your party you have your figs I
will be in attendance it's gonna be
great
how's that all right quit what Michael
you have no idea how high I can fly
[Music]
you